despite rising covet 19 infections and
the risk of violence
tens of thousands of colombians took to
the streets for a fourth straight day on
saturday
in bogota one group gathered at the
national park to continue
protesting against a controversial tax
reform that they say would raise taxes
on the middle class
at a time of great economic pain
among them 28 year old monica paredes
who lost their job during the pandemic
i still haven't been able to pay my
nine-year-old son's school tuition
because last year has been horrible for
me we are tired of not having a decent
health system
of not having institutions that work in
our favor
rising poverty and unemployment
following covet 19 restrictions have
people increasingly venting their anger
in the streets
openly defying official pleas to stay
home
it's easy to stay home when you're not
hungry but poor head of household
women don't have that luxury and have to
sell informally on the streets to
survive
that's why we're marching to tell this
government we are hungry and we need
help
isolated looting vandalism and clashes
mark the previous days
especially in colombia's third largest
city kali
where at least three people have died
allegedly shot by the police
but human rights organizations say the
real death toll could be much higher
on saturday most of the day was peaceful
until the police stopped a group of
demonstrators
the protesters are now trying to reach
the private home of president ivan duque
which is roughly
a couple of blocks up here there's a
huge police presence
in front of his condominium and as you
can see here the police
and anti-riot gear is stopping the
protesters from moving forward
as protesters tried to move on the
police shot tear gas
and stun grenades protesters responded
herding rocks and burning barricades
the chaos has forced president ivan
duque to backpedal on the tax reform
plans
promising to rewrite the bill excluding
taxes on basic food items
utilities and gasoline that angered
protesters
but some analysts believe it will not be
enough
i think that the government hasn't
understood that the political class is
not discussing that they think that just
withdrawing the tax reform is going to
be enough to appease the protest
uh but i think that we're past that
point and and
basically the sort of conversation that
we need from this moment
on has to deal with many more issues
than the tax reform
once again clashes continued into the
evening
signaling that protesters will not
easily stop
alessandra al jazeera bogota